[Música]
el acoso escolar es una lacra que no
cesa pendiente de erradicar buenas
tardes a todos y todas mi nombre es
rafael bailón ruiz soy docente y
desgraciadamente sé muy bien de lo que
hablo
según la oms organización mundial de la
salud por acoso escolar o bullying se
entiende intimidación o agresión física
psicológica o sexual contra una víctima
en edad escolar reiterada en el tiempo
que puede provocar daño temor o tristeza
en una víctima o en un grupo de víctimas
el término bullying fue acuñado por dan
always en 1993 a propósito de estudios
sistemáticos realizados en los años 70
en pleno siglo 20 y al hilo de suicidios
cometidos por algunos adolescentes en
este sentido quienes sufrieron y sufren
bullying sufren consecuencias diversas
tales como conductas suicidas
actitudes pasivas trastornos emocionales
o conductuales pérdida de interés en los
estudios bajo rendimiento académico o
episodios fóbicos entre otros pero
no podemos obviar un hecho un aspecto
por muy claro que nos pueda resultar las
redes sociales tales como twitter
instagram o youtube influyen y mucho de
forma decisiva en las conductas de los
adolescentes no en vano y a tenor de
numerosos estudios e investigaciones se
ha cifrado se cifra en torno a un 5% la
adicción a las mismas
una adicción mayor si cabe que otras
tales como tabaco o alcohol
pero si nos basamos en un estudio
publicado por la royal society of being
held
con chicos jóvenes de origen británico y
cuyas ciudades estaban comprendidas
entre los 14 y 24 años de edad
se extrajeron conclusiones interesantes
con secuencias desprendidas de un uso
inadecuado de las redes sociales tales
como sentimientos de soledad o depresión
mala imagen corporal entre otros
retrocedamos en el tiempo
vayámonos a marzo de 2020 se preguntarán
nos preguntaremos qué ocurre coincide
con el inicio del confinamiento
evidentemente los casos de acoso escolar
desaparecieron en esta fecha y
desaparecieron por algo obvio como es el
cierre de los centros educativos pero el
hostigamiento el chantaje o la extorsión
termino no
en ese momento se trasladan a otro
ámbito en este caso al ámbito
cibernético proliferaron y proliferan si
no hacemos nada al respecto los casos de
ciberacoso de esto y otro dato en mayo
de 2020 dos meses después del citado
confinamiento las peticiones de ayuda a
los teléfonos y chas de anar se cifran
en torno a un 3% en relación al
ciberacoso
problema mayúsculo este de gran
envergadura
al que debemos poner freno como también
debiéramos hacer lo mismo al respecto
con otros problemas no menores como es
el caso del grooming cuando adultos
intentan ganarse la confianza de menores
de edad víctimas propicias a cambio de
una recompensa de un botín a cambio de
favores sexuales
ante esta dramática situación ante esta
problemática que me plantea una pregunta
e intentó trasladar la misma a todos y
todas vosotros y vosotras que podemos
hacer los docentes ante esta
problemática
mi experiencia me dice que hemos de
transmitir confianza al alumnado
si se sienten cómodos evidentemente todo
será más fácil más llevadero podrán
revelar la situación sufrida pero hemos
de hacer más llevemos a cabo la
mediación muchas veces puede ayudar a
solucionar los conflictos eso sí
y es algo que con desgracia suelo ver
bastante nos quedamos en la simple
conversación como mera anécdota o
llevamos a cabo un seguimiento del
proceso me inclino por lo segundo y me
inclino también por involucrar por
implicar a las familias
cuántas veces he visto llorar a un
alumno cuántas veces me encontré con
chicos y chicas sin ganas de ir a la
escuela
yo desterraría una idea una creencia
errónea que nos está haciendo un flaco
favor y es esa creencia esa idea de que
en la escuela se enseña y en casa se
educa no señores estamos muy equivocados
la educación es responsabilidad de todos
y todas y deben intervenir familias y
también evidentemente docentes
pongámonos en la piel del que sufre del
agredido sepamos cómo se siente
ayudémosles practiquemos la mediación y
el trabajo cooperativo comentemos lo
entre el alumnado pero
como nos acercamos al acosado
yo les diría que debemos hacerles ver
que no están solos que cuentan con un
adulto como persona de máxima confianza
tanto si son ellos los que sufren como
si son otros
hagámosle ver que revelar la situación
sufrida por otros no les convierte en
chivato soplones o de latores promovamos
acciones útiles de una vez por todas
acciones útiles relacionadas con el uso
adecuado de las tics y de las redes
sociales tales como privatizar perfiles
explicarles el significado de la
etiqueta yo el otro día intentaba
explicárselo y cuando les pregunté qué
es eso de la etiqueta un alumno me dice
eso en la etiqueta de nescafé no
evidentemente ya hoy lo sabe es
importante de igual forma
evitemos que compartan imágenes
comprometidas o pertenecientes a otros
usuarios
y combatamos el insulto el chantaje la
extorsión la conducta agresiva de
cualquier usuario si fuera necesario
bloquear hagámoslo siempre y cuando
infrinjan las normas de convivencia pero
hay más
no podemos ni debemos convertir el acoso
escolar en un tema tabú
hablemos abiertamente de este tema de
esta problemática y analicemos sus
consecuencias
pero sigamos haciéndonos preguntas
y los padres que podemos hacer los
padres
los padres podemos y debemos hacer mucho
partamos de una sentencia por muy dura o
demoledora que resulte la falta de
comunicación familiar obstáculo para
combatir el acoso escolar
falta comunicación y en este hecho
insisten y han insistido los psicólogos
insisten en la necesidad de fomentar
habilidades sociales y relacionales
fomentamos la comunicación hablemos con
las partes hablemos con nuestros hijos
reforcemos su autoestima
pero también potenciamos la escucha
activa y el diálogo
de igual forma propiciemos encuentros
reuniones frecuentes con las escuelas no
en vano numerosos investigadores e
investigaciones señalan que el contacto
estrecho entre ambas esferas resulta
productivo para los chicos y chicas de
igual forma está contrastado el hecho de
que
un contacto estrecho entre familias y
profesores resulta muy positivo para los
adolescentes
dicho
numerosas investigaciones señalan que
aquellos padres que se preocupan más por
el proceso educativo en la educación de
sus hijos invierten también más tiempo
libre en ellos
hemos de hacer más mucho más porque no
olvidemos que se encuentran en una etapa
fundamental deben definir quiénes son o
van a ser
redes sociales videojuegos y medios de
comunicación transmiten una realidad
diferente un mundo alternativo y más
placentero que la propia realidad
pero
confunde los jóvenes realidad y ficción
debo decir que sí por desgracia sí
si nos basamos
un estudio publicado por la universidad
de michigan y coordinado por el
prestigioso psicólogo brian wilson se
analizaron consecuencias de
espacios televisivos tales como talent
shows o realities
los talent shows y realities influyen en
gran medida en los jóvenes gozan de su
aceptación y ellos imitan las conductas
de los personajes de los protagonistas a
los que consideran ídolos que forman
parte de dichos espacios en este estudio
que citaba se desprendían consecuencias
de esos formatos televisivos de ese
consumo tales como la tendencia a
disminuir las cualidades humanas el
excesivo culto a la apariencia física o
la imagen corporal y las conductas
agresivas
muchas veces derivadas en gran medida de
imitar a esos personajes
escuela y familia vuelvo a insistir en
este hecho de venir de la mano debemos
trabajar de manera compartida conjunta
una discontinuidad o desconexión entre
ambas esferas puede originar graves
problemas graves consecuencias en los
adolescentes principalmente en su
conducta pero
y los videojuegos son siempre malos
yo diría que evidentemente no todo
depende como con el resto de tecnología
del uso que les demos
así podrán ser una herramienta positiva
o no según la psicóloga maría hoyos los
videojuegos inciden en el desarrollo de
los adolescentes reforzando la
autoestima de nuestros hijos
cuando sean positivos pero de igual
forma
refuerzan aspectos tales como la
motricidad fina la concentración la
resolución de problemas el aprendizaje
de reglas e incluso la convivencia
dentro del amplio espectro de los
videojuegos
contamos con videojuegos con un marcado
carácter educativo otros que hacen
extensivo a la violencia y otros que
perpetúan o refuerzan estigma o
estereotipo negativo de igual forma
existen juegos que están de moda y que
presentan notable diferencia entre las
versiones gratuita y las versiones de
pago
ropas y complementos virtuales llevan
aparejado un estatus social
de hecho crisis identitaria y adicción
pueden originar graves problemas éstos
fuster en su obra nuestros hijos y su
videojuego dice que las modas funcionan
de igual forma en el mundo analógico o
en la realidad hasta el punto que si nos
salimos de la tendencia habitual o de la
mayoría podemos tener problemas podemos
convertirnos en víctimas de aquellos que
se sienten privilegiado y sufrir
conductas abusivas
qué papel juegan las instituciones
hablar de acoso escolar es por todo lo
expuesto un problema que no es sólo de
índole escolar es un problema que nos
afecta a todos y todas si nos basamos en
el estudio género 10 realizado por iñaki
piñuel en el año 2005 1 de cada 4
alumnos escolarizados de primaria a
bachillerato sufrían acoso escolar
y viran diréis vosotros y vosotras y
ahora hemos mejorado me baso nuestro
estudio en el año 2020 para decir que 1
de cada 5 alumnos escolarizados sufre
bullying pero doy otro dato más sólo el
15 por ciento de la víctima confesó la
situación sufrida a familiares o
profesores es cierto que contamos con
ámbitos de intervención diverso fiscalía
de menores policía asociaciones entre
otros pero es suficiente
resumiendo
los medios de comunicación deben
transmitir otros tipos de contenido
contenidos que dejen atrás los perfiles
difícilmente alcanzables por talent
shows o realities garantizar un uso
adecuado de las tics y de las redes
sociales debiera ser premisa competencia
de los mass-media o los medios de
comunicación y deben intervenir también
las instituciones públicas la creación
de campañas publicitarias que convivan
en la parrilla televisiva con los
números o anuncios publicitarios que
pueblan la pantalla puede ser un buen
punto de inflexión necesitamos acciones
integrales necesitamos de la
colaboración de todos y todas decía
xunta jarvis superar el abuso
no ocurre solo se hace paso a paso y
positivamente
que hoy sea el día en el que comienzas a
caminar a moverte hacia adelante y
añadir algo más una frase de un servidor
cosecha propia
no olvides quién lástima guarda silencio
o aplaude la agresión impiden frenar
este mal que mis deseos no caigan en
saco roto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]